this is from the daily wire it says
lego group is committed to removing
gender bias and harmful stereotypes from
its toys the company announced in a
statement on monday lego cited a study
by the gina davis institute on gender in
media
a non-profit pushing for gender balance
and entertainment of media showing the
majority of children believe that some
activities are just meant for girls
while others are meant for boys lego is
calling on parents and children to
champion inclusive play to change the
perception of children according to the
toy company
and this is happening at the same time
that the california governor gavin
newsom
signed a law
mandating in in the entire state of
california that large retail stores have
to offer toys in gender-neutral sections
so if they
if they employ 500 or more employees
across california
it is now a matter of law that they have
to have a gender-neutral section
for toys which of course that doesn't
achieve anything but just make it harder
for parents
who are shopping
you know trying to find toys for their
for their kids
because
all parents realize this like the vast
majority of kids
it's not because we tell boys oh here
are the here are the toys for boys you
have to play with those
oh you're a girl where you're you're
only allowed to have pink things and you
have to play with dolls
we don't tell our kids that it's just
that that's most of the time what they
naturally gravitate to from a very young
age
and it's it's always been an interesting
thing for me to have
you know i've kind of had this uh
been able to see this this this play out
in my own life having
a boy you know having fraternal twins
boy and a girl
and
raising them you know they were the
first kids that we had and uh we raised
them the same way and we had you know we
have a
even from a from a young age we had a
play room and with all the toys laid out
and we we never said to our daughter
well here's the girl section of toys
here's the boys section and you got to
stay over here we never said that we
just here's the toys go play
get out of mom and dad's hair for a
second and go play with the toys and
what would they do
almost every time
daughter's going for the dolls the sun's
going for the action figures
because it turns out that there is
something innate within you know there's
something about girls from a young age
where they have this kind of maternal
instinct and that's why they like to
play with the dolls and they'll sit
there and brush the doll's hair and
they'll they have fun changing the dolls
diapers boys for them for the most part
don't do that
there's something innate and ingrained
most parents recognize this
some parents recognize it to their heart
because they wish they don't want their
kid to subscribe to these gen these
awful gender stereotypes and yet they do
and so you get rid of the
gender segregation of the toy department
all you're doing is just making it hard
for the parents because they
because they're still looking for the
same kinds of toys
i think it was target did this a while
ago where they made a big deal about oh
we're not gonna we're not gonna separate
toys by boy versus girl anymore
but if you go to target still and you go
to the toy section they've still done
that i mean they've got all of the girl
type toys here and this aisle and all
the boy type toys they just don't have
the word boy and girl on it
and almost every parent who has a
daughter they're going to the girls
section
because this stuff is much of it is
innate
it is not determined by society
despite what we're told
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated